bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur arte france d'avoir si
vous me permettez cette question qui ne
va certainement pas vous plaire mais il
faut quand même la pause et ça concerne
la crédibilité de ce scrutin alassane
ouattara donc vainqueur avec plus de 94%
des voix à la faveur du boycott actif
d'opposants on sait que à peu près dix
sept mille bureaux de vote sur
vingt-deux mille qui ont ouvert leurs
portes le 31 octobre il ya eu des
violences à l'intérieur du pays pas
seulement à l'intérieur du pays
d'ailleurs une population aussi qui est
restée chez elle qui n'est pas forcément
aller voter par crainte des violences
dans ce contexte là comment vous
justifiez vous ce scrutin sa crédibilité
c'est plus tu es totalement crédit enfin
si vous avez chênois encore devoir de
vote n'est pas obligatoire a
pratiquement où le vote n'est pas
obligatoire
ceux qui ont décidé d'aller voter qui
vont puis divisés l'élection dont
c'était la première observation que je
voudrais faire maintenant la deuxième
vous à vous dire que n'ayez pas tendance
à dire que passer à des opposants qui
ont empêché le vote dans certaines zones
ce qui est ainsi démocratique et qui
file à l'enfant des règles de base de la
démocratie ce n'est pas passé quelques
nous ne faisons plus d'effet que vous
allez on veut mettre en pause ou un bar
aux éditoriaux de la qualifier de vote
il ya eu encore dit moi je vous informe
que si près de quatre mille lieues du
maître des 12 millions de voix il n'y a
eu que cinq ans ont été faites il est
alors partie de ses terres ça je peux
vous dire que pour nous le vote est
crédible il est accepté par les
ivoiriens et plus de 3 millions de
personnes sont à l'évoquer à partie de
ses terres sans considérer que oui
le président alassane ouattara a été élu
comporte confortablement palais du bagne
qui de manière majoritaire qui ont donné
les 4-14 poupin maintenant fois que des
individus aient décidé de ne pas aller à
des élections ou bien et fait des fautes
et des daaf
le blocage parce que leurs problèmes à
mesure on dit chez nous le vote n'est
pas obligatoire
donc ceux qui veulent aller voter maman
bouquet qui devait pas aller voter
ils n'y vont pas alors maintenant
qu'elle est ça nous a trahis confirmé
comme le vainqueur de cette élection
présidentielle que va-t-il faire parce
qu'en ce moment le le contexte est
compliqué en côte d'ivoire plusieurs
leaders de l'opposition étaient arrêtées
plusieurs résidences d'opposants sont
encerclés quelle télé la suite
à moi de continuer à gouverner et plus
de développer notre pays est le plus
important c'est nous prouvons une
minorité qui ont fui le débat
démocratique et qui de manière très
grave a appelé à la ville de 800 civique
avec des impacts actif avec son
corollaire de morts et mais des gens
vont répondre devant la justice
et ça franchement non au niveau des
réalités nous allons insister pour que
le président ouattara créé les
conditions pour qu'il n'y ait plus
d'impunité
voyez vous madame il ya eu une bande
avait ce petit elliptique commune de
kouassi kouassikro c'était en fait de
jumeaux et qui est morte parce que
d'individus de l'opposition en déclaré
qu'il fallait bloquer les voir et elle
concernant les violences pré mais le
temps d'aller non concernant les
violences pré et post électorale est ce
qu'il faudrait pas qu'il y ait une
enquête internationale pour faire la
lumière parce qu'on n'a pas encore de
bilan
annie roy enfin une enquête
internationale que vous allez du balai
on a des malfrats qui ont les
compétences nous voit cette enquête là
pourquoi voulez vous touche
consacré aux aux internationaux la côte
d'ivoire dispose de compétences pour
pouvoir gérer ses jambes situation on
n'a pas besoin d'enquêté internationale
la réalité c'est qu'il ya une jeune dame
témoin qui est morte en couches
parce qu'ils ont bloqué la route est
directement adapté pour lui on n'a même
pas besoin d'aller même faire des
enquêtes aussi qu'il ya des victimes
parmi ses militants et il a eu
l'habitude de passer à l'opposition a
demandé à tree hill et dégager un
boycott actif s'ils n'avaient pas
demandé cela juste l'opposition qu'elles
ont fait un gouvernement de transition
civile à la suite de cela plusieurs
plusieurs résidences d'opposants étant
certes et dans celle d' henri
konan-bédié le profil plaît le grand
david jean richard ado affirme qu il
n'est ni en arrestation ni en résidence
surveillée mais il ne peut pas sortir
comment on qualifier aujourd'hui l état
actuel des choses le président henri
konan bédié à 86 va macd est âgée et un
qui va accompagner dans cette volonté de
débiteurs privés ont dit ou d'amande
derrière nous sommes un état de droit
nous privant la république s'appelle
alassane ouattara même jusqu'à là et la
programmation officielle des résultats
ils étaient entre le cri d'alarmé jeudi
et quand des individus sains aux
desseins inavoués s'élève vous dis qu au
maire place un conseil national de
transition
vous comprenez que et ces personnes là
va être traduit devant la justice
on ne peut pas une croissance alors
qu'une descente avait assuré ses avocats
pour qu'ils n'arrivent pas à nous de ne
pas m'être que je partais pas râler en
france ne brisera alarm à quoi et à des
individus jean l'humilation cette
optique on met en place un comité
un conseil national de transition mais
ça que vous soulevez tamaris n'guessan
un mot d'apaisement des films qui n
avait pas besoin d'être mieux paraît il
a lui même mis en cui droit au plan
moral parce que tout est quatre gars ivt
lui ça lui même n'y a plus l'ombre noire
on n'a pas de l'écouter d'état barré par
milliers pour qu'il est mis en place et
descendent
on doit conclure est ce que il ya
l'espoir d'avoir un geste d'apaisement
peut-être un dialogue politique vient
partiellement les effets possibles on
dit chacune des équipes en panne et que
ceux qui ont donné le moteur 1 d'abord
reconnaître cuisson responsables étaient
d'intuitif et après if en paix et mener
des actions devenu d'apaisement passé
dans ce pays
mais cela ne se sont jamais sentis
responsables
donc c'est vous dire que tant qu'il n'y
a pas eu pendant ce temps qu'il n'ya pas
ici par l'élève unités on ne peut pas
l'amener à revoir merci à vous d'avoir
répondu en direct à nos questions sur
arte france rappelle que vous êtes
membre du conseil politique du rhdp le
parti au pouvoir en côte d'ivoire